ahmed devrait être à l'école à cette
heure ci mais pour lui la fin des
classes a sonné il ya plus de trois ans
avec le son des explosions et des tirs
dans la banlieue de damas où il vivait
avec sa famille
imaginez que vous ayez arrêtez votre
travail que la vie c'est ce pour vous et
votre famille rey comment une être
humain peut se sentir comment croyez
vous que quelqu'un dont la vie s'est
arrêtée il ya 4 5 ans ce sens les
meilleurs gymnastes ahmad n'aime pas
repenser à ce moment où sans comprendre
ce que cela signifiait vraiment ils ont
tout laissé derrière forcé à l'exil
elle les facs opto j'ai tout perdu dans
mon pays mes ambitions mais réalisation
mais je sens qu au canada je pourrais
accomplir des choses
éduquer mes enfants ma femme et moi
pourrons utiliser nos compétences et
c'est ce qu'il espère faire très bientôt
mohammad un avocat sa femme et leurs
trois enfants ont été acceptées par le
canada comme réfugiés ils n'attendent
plus que le signal de départ quand on
l'a dit j'ai senti que ma vie reprenait
en quittant l'ambassade
j'ai retrouvé l'espoir mohammad c'est
que depuis les attentats de paris
de nombreuses voix s'élèvent au canada
et ailleurs pour affirmer leur
inquiétude de voir autant de réfugiés
arrivés si vite mais pour le syrien
d'abord interrogé par le haut
commissariat aux réfugiés des nations
unies et ensuite révéré au canada le
processus de sélection a semblé très
long trop loeb nous ça nous a surpris
nous avons fait une autre vue puis une
autre puis une autre ensuite des examens
médicaux a dans ce sens un peu comme
dans un labyrinthe perdu en attendant de
savoir si on va partir ou pas avec plus
d'un million deux cent mille réfugiés
enregistrés ici et des dizaines et des
dizaines de milliers qu'ils ne sont pas
le liban considère avoir fait le plein
il ne permet plus l'enregistrement de
nouveaux réfugiés par le haut
commissariat des nations unies à
d'autres de faire leur part pour le
liban la perspective que des pays
resserre les critères d'admissibilité ou
ralentissent l'accueil des réfugiés
syriens est une bien mauvaise nouvelle
les réfugiés syriens sont partout au
liban et vivent dans des conditions
souvent difficiles les camps ne sont pas
permis par les autorités libanaises
ce qui n'empêche pas les campements
informels de tapisser le paysage ici les
parents ont obtenu la permission d'un
cultivateur de planter leurs tentes à
même les champs de pommes de terre
en échange de leur travail eux ne sont
pas rémunérés
alors les enfants aussi sont mises à
contribution contre environ 5 dollars
par jour
pour ahmad lui arrive à payer les 250
dollars de loyer mensuel pour cet
appartement à quelques kilomètres des
champs ces enfants n'ont pas à
travailler mais c'est pour eux qu'il
rêve du canada même s'ils habitent ils
les rigueurs de l'hiver l'inquiète un
pic à fait c'est assez de temps perdu
l'avenir de mes enfants est en train de
s'évaporer et il est convaincu que sa
famille arrivera à s'intégrer à sa
nouvelle terre d'accueil
c'est une société multiculturelle et
multiethnique
si on n'adhère pas à ses valeurs on
retourne au moyen-âge veut plus regarder
en arrière
ici marie-eve bédard radio canada majdel
anjar ou liban